مقابل القاله الخارجيه الفلسطينيه انها
تحمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه
الكامله والمباشره عما تسمى مسيره الاعلام
الاستفزازيه ونتائجها وتداعياتها ليس فقط
في القدس وانما على ساحه الصراع وفق
تعبيرها جانبها حذرت رئاسه الفلسطينيه من
ان المسيره ستؤدي الى التوتر وتفجير
الاوضاع
هذا وداعا القيادي في حركه حماس مشير
المصري اهالي القدس والضفه الغربيه
والداخل الى التصدي للمسيره والاشتباك مع
قوات الاحتلال وقال المصري ان المقاومه
رهن الاشاره للدفاع عن المسجد الاقصى
والقدس وافشال مخططات التهويده
نحن على ثقه كامله بمقاومتنا الفلسطينيه
التي تعد العده لتحرير بيت المقدس من
براءه المغتصبين انها دوما
رهن الاستعداد للحفاظ على اولى القبلتين
وتاني المسجدين وثالث الحرمين الشريفين
وافشاري مخططات الاحتلال